[Aplausos]
ó
nós seremos convidados a tomar decisões
que podem mudar o rumo da vida da gente
quer seja tem um filho a deus a escola
que a gente vai cursar onde a gente vai
morar
o trabalho que a gente vai ter nesses
momentos não adianta muito ajudar a
gente tem que olhar dentro da alma da
gente viu que nos agrada porque nos dias
e aí decidir eu comecei a trabalhar com
15 anos no acidente
naquela época não existia e mail existe
workflow que existem algumas meninas que
levavam papéis de um lado do outro em um
departamento para o outro eu podia
simplesmente listar papéis foi eu podia
acreditar que estava ajudando fazer um
fechamento de câmbio ajudando a fazer a
fazer uma operação de seu bebê e com
isso eu comecei a aprender o que as
pessoas faziam não só levar o papel mas
eu tinha a oportunidade de aprender o
que as pessoas estavam fazendo ea
oportunidade de ajudá las caso fosse
preciso de e também de de me organizar
então eu não precisava sair correndo
cada papel mas eu sabia que o momento
devia fazer cada coisa
com isso fui aprendendo chegou a taxa
chega a época que eu ia fazer minha
faculdade
eu trabalhava de dia e estudava de noite
e não queria fazer cursinho decidi que
eu ia fazer economia estudar em escola
estadual simples diz costa
e comecei a fazer cursinho de final de
semana
algumas pessoas às vezes dizem é difícil
estudar porque eu tenho que trabalhar
mas pra mim era viável estudar de dia e
estuda à noite e trabalhar de dia e ao
final de semana ao longo de uns quatro
meses eu fiz cursinho os finais de
semana é possível perguntar sem pior se
namora que ora se encontra os amigos
obviamente nesse período não fazer nada
disso mas o namoro aguentou consiga
entrar na faculdade fizer cursei a
faculdade toda começou foi trabalhando e
logo que acho que é o banco me promoveu
a secretária e aí tinha uma outra
decisão importante decidi secretário a
função de secretária naquela época logo
ganhava bons salários porém ela tinha
uma carreira limitada
não era o que eu queria para mim aí eu
pedi ao banco
se fosse para uma outra função que eu
queria crescer 30 que eu quisesse
operadora eu queria fazer outras coisas
e aí comecei a ter outras atividades
não é fácil um pouquinho mais de tempo
para receber mas eu sabia que eu ia
aprender muito mais
foi trabalhando assim dessas atividades
até que concluí a faculdade ea faculdade
ou sugerir ao final quase ao final da
faculdade como os professores no chamado
dez alunos da faculdade e sugeriram se a
gente podia organizar um grupo para
estudar com mestrado na faculdade também
tinha poucos anúncios mestrandos e eles
achavam que acho que nos ajudassem que
teria potencial pra cursar novamente no
fim de semana está o sacrificado
trabalhava de dia e estudava de noite na
faculdade e aos finais de semana nos
preparávamos para mestrado no último mês
antes do exame do mestrado e cinco
amigos saímos de férias e passávamos o
todos os dias de domingo a domingo nos
preparando para prestar o exame
entrei no mês passado mas se perder o
namorado aí já era demais muito era
muito tempo só estudando trabalhando e
aí ficamos na mão mas foi uma boa
decisão passado um tempo voltamos a
namorar nos casamos e tivemos uma filha
passado dois anos
era impressionante a gente vê morávamos
em são paulo sou paulistana nascida
nascida na cidade de são paulo ea a
havia uma quantidade enorme de crianças
naquela época tinha que pintavam
para-brisa de carro que tinham esmola e
t ea minha filha lá estudar e eu pensava
daqui a alguns anos vai ser impossível
ela vai estar trabalhando e um monte de
gente roubando não era difícil imaginar
o que aconteceu em são paulo no brasil
não via o que acontece nos dias de hoje
daí decidimos mudar para dominar
mudei para blumenau sem trabalhar numa
agência do citibank em blumenau
e aqui vem trabalhando eu já estava
formando quase 16 anos recentemente e me
incomodava virar uma plaquinha
decentemente era muito cômodo era
confortável e naquela época era muito
comum as pessoas sentarem
o banco que se aposentarem no mesmo
banco mas isso pra mim não era bastante
confortável e isso me incomodava
bastante até porque aí tenho que voltar
um pouquinho
logo que eu entrei no citibank a era uma
época de muita transformação começaram a
surgir os primeiros computadores e aí
começou um processo de demissão de
várias pessoas que na planilha que tinha
15 anos pessoas de 40 anos eram velhos e
aqueles velhos todos estavam sendo
mandado embora e morriam né porque
morreu de verdade e de verdade não é
porque para que uma facto porque não
tinha mais onde trabalhar e não tinha o
que fazer e eu dizer isso não vai
acontecer comigo e vou me preparar a
vida toda e vou me aposentar os 40 anos
eu paro de trabalhar e vou ter o que
fazer
e de fato se me preparando a vida toda
para trabalhar e arrumar o que fazer
estava em blumenau quando já estava
estava em blumenau quando começamos a
pensar o que vou fazer na minha segunda
carreira
não dá para bancar a vida toda bancária
é uma atividade onde você mata um leão
por dia que você consegue matar um leão
por dia as pessoas perguntam 2 acho que
é possível talvez uns três
então cada vez e fazer mais mas não é
uma atividade de gente velha de verdade
hoje em dia 40 é mas não retirou mais de
60 a 70 de fato um bancário de 60 anos
em vir aí o bom continuava trabalhando
acabei o meu mestrado já estava clara da
china segundo filho
quando recebi um convite pra ir pro
banco nacional era um desafio bastante
complicado banco nacional era um banco
quebrando um banco brasileiro eto'o
havia vontades boatos de que ele ia
quebrar city bank um banco sólido mas eu
não queria vir a chapinha do citibank e
verifynow boca voltou para o banco
nacional foi pra lá conheci o banco
começamos a trabalhar firme e diretora
de produtos e continuar trabalhando mas
aí o casa voltei para são paulo
realmente não dava mais para trabalhar
em blumenau
esse sistema financeiro brasileiro todo
em são paulo
aí fomos pra voltar pra lá mas aí o
casamento acabou e aí continente
continuei trabalhando pagando e o
o meu segundo filho já tinha lá um dia
recebi o convite para trabalhar no big
bosta um banco pequeno sem nenhuma
tradição de produtos cast mesmo produzir
ximenes são produtos de serviço de
cobrança pagamento que requer rede de
agências e que todo mundo dizia é
impossível ser um grande banco de
serviços em rede a agência era um
desafio importante porque acreditava que
era possível mas tinha que ter alguma
coisa mais eu sou movido a desafios
acredito que ninguém pode fazer sucesso
ninguém pode ser bem sucedido se estiver
fazendo aquilo que todo mundo faz
se você tiver uma multidão e em uma
fazenda as pessoas dizem ser uma vaca
cabeceira
se todas as vacas tiverem do mesmo
tamanho se todas as iguais todos são
iguais se chegaram à cabeceira uma que
saiu de cima é aquela que você vai ver
se você tiver fazendo o que todo mundo
faz ninguém vai notar
então você tem que fazer uma coisa
diferente uma oportunidade se eu fosse
proposta de fazer uma coisa diferente e
aí a minha filha de uma ajuda
fundamental
ela me fez três perguntas que decidiram
por mim ela tinha 10 anos e me perguntou
viaja - eu me achava muito na marcação
na banca nacional ficava no rio e morar
em são paulo a e além de todas as
viagens pelo resto dos núcleos do país
viaja - não vai ter que não viaja nunca
mais obviamente haja menos ganha menos
paga 10 anos exatamente desse jeito ela
pergunta
ganhámos aqui não vou ficar rica mas
obviamente ganha mais você gosta de
ficar sempre fora de casa não sabe nada
acontece e claro que não é obviamente
ela tinha decidido não quer dizer que a
minha filha de 10 anos
eu gosto de não saber nada do que
acontece com uma excelente decisão um
ano depois banco nacional quebrou e eu
estava no beco mostra com a oportunidade
de transformar big bosta um dos maiores
bancos de serviço do país e de satuba e
que possam se tornar um rolo de alguns
anos um dos maiores bancos de serviço do
país com uma equipe de pessoas
fantásticas pessoas que de fato
trabalham os outros que de fato
desenvolvemos vários produtos dos
clientes entendendo
transformando os produtos não com tanta
tecnologia não tanto dinheiro mas com
muita criatividade com muito esforço com
muito empenho
a cada dia a gente fazer uma coisa
diferente uma inovação alguma coisa e
fazer com que os clientes cada vez
ficassem mais diversas vezes o bradesco
o itaú é procuravam agentes assim eu
tenho certeza que você é maior que a
gente é claro que não com certeza ser
melhores acharem que eu sou pequenininho
com certeza vocês são maiores eles
diziam se a gente olhar que vocês têm o
tíquete grande ea gente tem um time
pequeno
com certeza você maio com isso foi
passando e com isso tanto eu quanto o
pessoal da minha equipe recebeu o
convite de tudo que é bom
o psb ce santo andré na final os bancos
e eu fazendo convite a minha decisão foi
de continuar no benfica gosto era muito
é muito trabalhado muito bem era muito
agradável uma equipe fantástica pessoas
do banco de modo geral que trabalhavam
juntos a menor satisfação ver a pessoa
da portaria dizer olha o cliente só falo
isso um garçom do restaurante dizer
condição já aconteceu isso não seria
então era um banco que trabalhávamos
juntos talvez não junto com todas as
pessoas mas pelo menos que vã a nossa
equipe trabalhava bastante junto
irei vice-presidente de do do bank
boston quando o banco itaú comprou o
bertin mostra pra mim eu tinha certeza
que sairia do hospital porque todas as
estatais estatais são aqueles casino
pelo banco em variavelmente saiba abril
quando fui convidado a ficar em casa
ficasse ou o banco faria uma única área
de produtos se eu não ficasse eles e
deixar as áreas todas quebradas em
várias áreas de produto em respeito a
todos os meus funcionários é tudo que a
gente tinha feito junto eu achei que eu
tinha que ficar por mais que eu já
tivesse a fazenda em rio do sul
por mais que desde os 40 anos a gente já
tinha uma um plano de vir pra cá de
fazer a fazenda todo o fim de semana a
gente já vinha pra cá pra poder para
poder um dia realizar o plano de sair
mais uma vez eu tinha que postergar o
plano de aposentadoria e e e ficaram
baktawng uma tantas que a experiência um
banco grande
o banco onde muitas coisas pra fazer um
banco com muita tecnologia e trabalhamos
até que em 2008 foi diagnosticada com
câncer mas continuei trabalhando mesmo
com câncer mesmo no hospital ainda
responde e mail fazer tudo e superior já
faz dez anos e nunca tive nada
o tom passou mais dois anos resolvi sair
já era hora de sair já que não tinha
tinha feito que tinha que fazer já tinha
feito inclusive a fusão com o unibanco
fusão é juntar os dois bancos que é uma
outra experiência fantástica
juntei os dois bancos até tu sido feito
aí a hora de aposentar realmente
aposentei já estava aqui fiquei aqui
quase 116 mesmo quando fui convidada pra
montar ou bambu origem era um banco
totalmente digital do nada que não tinha
coisa nenhuma começar do zero um desafio
fantástico outra coisa que ninguém nunca
fez nessa coisa que tinha como fazer
aí voltei voltei mais dois anos montei o
banco quando de fato o banco já estava
montado já tinha equipe já tinha gente
aí vim pra cá já estou aqui há cinco
anos e aí a pergunta que venha como é
que esse negócio se o office girl se
virar diretor executivo de um grande
banco se vira presidente de um banco foi
presidente do banco original e se vira
presidente do mundo olha eu às vezes
pensava assim é trabalho duro né parem
em contábeis noites em cada plano e aqui
são uma uma brincadeira é aqui no brasil
bancários pararam noite e finais de
semana para abrir um banco com duas
moedas uma moeda
aí eu cada plano era uma invenção
diferente
a gente fica abismado lá no posto uma
vez que recebemos um e-mail e dizer
daqui a um ano haverá o euro a gente
olhava a um ano ou um ano era preparar
que haveria muita moeda e todas as
moedas e quisermos ser um fim-de-semana
incontáveis meses mas a europa e levou
um ano para fazer ele se precisaram que
deu tudo certo mas a gente fez com
várias vezes ínfima bom tudo isso tudo
isso sob as obras estão mais organizado
o ovo mas também lá estão bancário mais
velho aqui o bancário tem que ser jovem
perder
e só está a gente dizia bastante data
viver nesse ritmo de plano bastante só
que as pessoas morrem elas morrem gente
joga fora começa de novo aí
bom aí o bom aposentei bem pra cá e the
office gão virei fereira diretora e foi
com muito trabalho foi com muito empenho
e trabalhando em conjunto e trabalhando
a equipe foi planejado mas eu acho que a
coisa mais importante mais importante é
fazer diferente é não querer fazer igual
é sair da zona de conforto é fazer
aquilo que essas pessoas não estão
fazendo é arriscado claro que você está
fazendo aquilo que ninguém está fazendo
é outro confortável faz aquilo que as
pessoas estão fazendo
se errar erro com todo mundo porém você
vai acertar se acertou com todo mundo
não tem nenhum grande diferencial pra
mim deu certo e uma carreira bem
sucedida mudar porque mudar porque não
dá para se levantar e aos 60 anos
de fato nem ver e mudando porque mudar o
mundo quer 100% virtual no mapa no banco
tudo é virtual do mundo 100% real já
tinha esse plano da fazenda há alguns
anos nem assim a gente já vinha fazendo
e tem essa coisa de 100% real 100%
virtual dá muito equilíbrio bastante
controle para as pessoas
eu tinha às vezes a impressão de que
você chega no banco tem uma crise e as
coisas vão acontecer de um dia para o
outro você vai conseguir um sistema novo
você vai conseguir um processo diferente
você vai conseguir alguma coisa
não adianta gritar com uma vaca leva
nove mesmo dizer umas e não adianta
discutir comigo ele tem o tempo dele pra
maturar pra você poder político
essas coisas não entre para você saber
que mesmo que você tem a impressão que
você vai gritar com alguém as coisas vão
acontecer tudo tem seu tempo você você
tem que respeitar o tempo as pessoas
você tem que respeitar o tempo dos
animais a respeitar o tempo da natureza
então essas coisas me dava equilíbrio ao
longo de muitos anos vive e se essas
duas coisas né desde os 40 anos até os
60 anos fui vivendo assim dos dois lados
e por que uma fazenda e porque rio do
sul
meu marido segundo marido era daqui e
não só a gente precisa manter o homem no
mas a gente também precisa trazer as
pessoas da cidade para o campo com todos
os conhecimentos que as pessoas têm
trabalho é trabalho qualquer trabalho
depende 50% de inspiração 50% de
criatividade disciplina trabalho a
determinação qualquer trabalho é a mesma
coisa
requer foco requer metas requer
organização tem que ter planejamento tem
que ter organização quem fazer reunião e
não importa se as pessoas são
alfabetizados ou não não importa se elas
têm mestrado não as pessoas entendem dá
muito orgulho você conversar com uma
pessoa ea esposa de um caminhoneiro dia
sendo a sandra conseguiu ontem 41
carretas mas amanhã nós vamos fazer mais
porque todo mundo sabia o que aquilo
significava todo mundo sabia o que a
gente esperava o resultado daquilo
então não importa se você está no meio
da berrini se você está numa fazenda de
gado na verdade as coisas são as mesmas
e agora agora a gente tem uma fazenda de
gado de leite
estamos rumando para gado de corte na
inúmeras razões a gente prefere ficar
com corte
fizemos um grande projeto de
certificação não chega ser 11 orgânica
mas a gente reduz bastante o uso de
adubo e e consegue dar um uso adequado
pra todo lado buquê para todos como
estrume que as barracas eram e agora
damos um projeto junto com o pessoal de
pomerode pra fazer um biodigestor este
ainda está começando e é onde mais a
gente vai não sei
não dá também para parar de trabalhar
não dá para trabalhar 40 anos 60 anos
esperaria viver mais 60
a minha mãe tem 100
bom o bastante
o portanto a gente tem que ao longo da
vida ver se a gente está fazendo uma
coisa adequada essa gente está sendo
feliz a gente gosta do que está fazendo
e vai continuar em sua vida mudou esse
cenário mudou
a gente tem que se planejar não dá pra
ser macaco datapopular de galinhada
mas também não dá pra ser burro e ficar
espantado porque um dia decide uma coisa
ficar naquilo
a gente tem que sempre planejar e ficar
no equilíbrio de persistir e desistir
encerrando com a frase do livro a
insustentável leveza do ser de milan
kundera a vida humana se acontece uma
vez ea gente jamais vai ter a
oportunidade de saber se a gente toma
uma boa ou uma má decisão porque em
todas as situações que nós só vamos
poder decidir uma nós nunca vamos ter
uma segunda ou a terceira uma quarta
decisão para poder decidir se a decisão
foi boca
eu sempre acho que a gente tem que fazer
alguma coisa que acho que a nossa alma
disse que se é bom aprender com ela e
segui em frente
então um dia me convidaram pra mim aqui
foi uma grande oportunidade de aprender
uma grande oportunidade de dizer o que
eu fiz na vida então muito obrigado
[Aplausos]